allora innanzitutto grazie a fare
spoilerato il fatto che sono un
matematico perché io in realtà dove non
toccarmi questa questa carta perché
perché vi parlerò di due sfide allora
una sfida e mia personale ed è anche
quella di essere qua proprio perché sono
un matematico e allora voi direte
sì ma è dov'è la sfida ecco io vorrei
mostrarvi la faccia che generalmente o
davanti quando parlo di matematica ecco
sinceramente rende bene con la trovata è
il rum
ma sì ho detto sì ok e lei l'ho vista la
ri conosco molto bene e allora è
veramente ecco sapete perché i
matematici hanno il clichè che vanno in
un mondo astratto un pò isolato con penn
ok non è un clichet l'albero è in realtà
io faccio matematica applicata e allora
dopo un attimo per forza allargare gli
orizzonti necessariamente perché la
matematica applicata vuole essere
efficace vuole agire vuole rappresentare
vorrebbe fare modelli devo guardarmi e
quel che è peggio
devo andare in mezzo alla gente
ecco questa è la sensazione veramente un
po scheuring di terrore ma ci provo
ok adesso andiamo alla seconda sfida
quindi la mia sfida più avanti gli dirò
come ho tentato di risolverla e come sto
tentando di portarla avanti
ma adesso andiamo alla seconda la
seconda è proprio quella della
matematica allora la matematica
tradizionalmente è stata veramente molto
efficace nell'ambito della fisica fisica
nel senso di meccanica naturalmente è
stata molto molto efficace
poi ha avuto una seconda sfida la
seconda sfida è stata quella della bio
matematica
ecco qua era già un po il discorso della
del fatto che è comunque la matematica
si si si si guarda un po intorno
e probabilmente qui l'idea che voglio
dirvi che sto un po pure io spolverando
quello che anticiperà un po dopo e
cercherò di parlare un po di crisi
finanziarie analizzate con la matematica
eccola più matematica è stata la seconda
sfida che la matematica secondo me a cui
ha risposto veramente alla grande io
stessa per la verità ho fatto un lavoro
sul sull'apertura degli strand del dna
quando sono soggetti a un flusso di
temperatura piuttosto alto
allora lì è interessante perché comunque
ci sono delle basi che interagiscono
però sempre illegali sono chimici fisici
ma la cosa si fa ancora più la sfida si
fa ancora più pressante
quando le interazioni sono fra esseri
viventi perché già un pesce ecco già di
per sé è una realtà veramente piuttosto
complessa decisamente però addirittura
in questo caso nel caso di un branco di
pesci sta interagendo delle interazioni
a delle interazioni che naturalmente non
sono eccessivamente complicate sono
interazioni di tipo gioco però a danno
luogo a dei fenomeni emergenti ecco qua
c'è un po la pulling nei sistemi
complessi emergono dai fenomeni che sono
interessanti e nel caso dei pesci come
anche degli stormi sicuramente
conoscerete abbastanza questo discorso
sono strategici nel senso che i pesci
sono questo perché vogliono sfuggire
predatorie allora li confondono loro
appaiono come un grande pesce
diciamo la strategia è vincente perché
alla fine non vengono mangiati però il
discorso è ancora la sfida alla
matematica ab ancora più avanti va
ancora più avanti perché adesso l'idea è
di fare interagire in quelli che sono i
sistemi sociali di fare interagire alle
persone ecco forse è qui per la verità
non è tanto efficace è risultata come
nei pesci
ma voi sapete che le persone sono un bel
po più complesse sono soprattutto molto
eterogenea tra questi bambini c'è la
ghiera più spaventato più nervoso e chi
ha provato di meno qui naturalmente c'è
pure sotto sotto il fatto del leader
cioè solo una maestra è fatto fare le
prove magari forse qualcuno in più
comunque insomma è sempre un fenomeno di
questi complessi e l'idea è quella che è
la matematica sia in grado in qualche
maniera di potere fare dei modelli che
in qualche maniera analizzano questo
potrebbero analizzarli per esempio per
quanto riguarda poi il discorso non lo
so da un'uscita da uno stadio in
condizioni di panico insomma può
diventare veramente interessante il
discorso è ecco questo cosa c'entra il
nome economico
innanzitutto è un gran bel vedere e poi
voglio dire il discorso è che l'altra
sfida successiva è stata quella di
sistemi complessi che non possiamo
visualizzare cioè come pesci il branco
il balletto e allora sono sistemi però
complessi in cui più o meno la logica è
la stessa nel senso voglio dire solo in
dvd che interagiscono e che provocano
non so interagiscono dei mercati
finanziari
adesso finora non finora però fino un po
di tempo fa classicamente la matematica
ha risposto con con lui col nome
economicus allora no ma economico se
veramente un supereroe cancella tutta la
eterogeneità quindi è solo lui
rappresenti rappresenta tutti siamo
assolutamente tutti uguali e poi è
perfettamente razionale cento per cento
razionale nel senso che conosce la
utility perché in ogni istante la
conosce la ottimizza è questo lo fa
avendo sempre il cento per cento delle
informazioni sa tutto
lavora in maniera perfettamente coerente
questo nei modelli classici mio classici
e fra l'altro è avulso dal network
perché solo agisce soltanto lui
ora come capita insomma io dove lui in
particolare non ho mai incontrato ma
neanche no
no mi gusto devo dire mi sembra un po un
po irreale come proposta io diciamo che
potrei più lui lui e magari non è
perfettamente razionale è quello che si
chiama ecco chiamarlo irrazionale forse
troppo nei modelli si chiama razionalità
limitata bound rationality non è non
ottimizza probabilmente non conosce
perfettamente tutto però come vedete nel
momento in cui interagisce con delle
interazioni che possa essere anche
relativamente semplici riesce a creare
un fenomeno fare emergere un fenomeno
complesso macroscopico che è molto
efficace non riesce riesce a non farsi
mangiare direi che è decisamente
efficace
allora la sfida della matematica è di
questo perché di riuscire però a pesare
cioè a misurare quantità che non è molto
facile cioè io devo pensare
la banda drache analiti non chiamiamole
razionalità perché magari sembra quasi
offensivo però devo misurarla perché la
devo mettere nel mio modello la devo
metto nella mia matematica devo poi fare
partire la macchina di dei modelli per
lavorarci sopra per tirare fuori dei
risultati
e questa questa è stata una delle sfide
ultime che l'ama tema che è stata posta
ai modelli e alla modellizzazione
matematica nell'ambito delle scienze
sociali dell'economia della finanza è ok
torniamo alla via in qualche maniera
abbiamo provato in dei lavori questi
sono dei titoli di alcuni lavori abbiamo
fatto con dei colleghi è come vedete c'è
la parola io ho voluto mettere proprio
questo titolo perché c'è la parola
altruismo set match quindi stiamo
mettendo in un modello che poi il
modello cinetico particelle attive un
degli stocastici questo non è importante
soltanto dire che c'è dietro una teoria
comunque molto matematica molto diciamo
ben fondata
però stiamo mettendo all'interno delle
quantità che in effetti diciamo
non erano prima presenti come
l'altruismo l'egoismo in una dinamica
che è una dinamica complessa di welfare
per esempio oppure fare paralleli fra
scienze sociali e dinamiche dinamica
delle folle e adesso quindi warning
perché le prime ultime equazioni che
metterò è giuro non basta sono l'ultima
e queste sono le cose per dirvi che ok
la matematica acciaio
non voglio barare e questo modello
cinetico celle twork naturalmente i
network possono essere anche molto
grandi e quindi la matematica ha bisogno
di nuovi strumenti di essere affiancata
da nuovi strumenti da quella che è la
materia della computazione quindi
l'information technology quindi l'uso di
big data perché network possa essere
molto grandi ma togliamogli ha subito
ok togliamo via le formule e andiamo a
qualche risultato per per dirvi quelle
formule che cosa ci dicono poi fanno
arrivare per esempio al a un fenomeno
emergente in questo caso diciamo sul
lungo termine che ci dice che nel caso
in cui io in questa grande massa di
agenti e razionalità limitata che
giocano tra di loro e se giocano in
maniera competitiva se sono competitivi
l'uno con l'altro la soluzione che io
trovo sul reddito quindi quelle sono
proprio le classi di reddito quindi da
sinistra a destra voi vedete le classi
dalle meno abbienti e lo più ambienti
più poveri e più ricchi
allora come vedete quello che avviene
sul lungo periodo è che si distribuisce
il reddito in questa maniera
quindi si polarizza quindi ci sono molti
molto poveri e molti molto ricchi è la
classe media va via
praticamente scompare perché a destra
vedrete il valore medio del reddito che
praticamente si azzera c'è questa
polarizzazione che è tipicamente una
disuguaglianza
se invece c'è un gioco di cooperazione
quindi gioco relativamente semplice
quello che avviene sul lungo termine è
un
un effetto di questo genere cioè
decisamente molto più positivo cioè le
classi diciamo dai più ricchi e sono
hanno una frequenza molto più alta e
quindi sono sono molto più c'è una
crescita come vedete a destra c'è una
crescita economica
un trend di crescita economica nel tempo
e poi naturalmente si va stabilizzando
però c'è la crescita e allora l'idea è
questa la sfida e vi dicevo io ho
risposto alla sfida che mi è stata posta
mettendomi in gioco nel senso ho dovuto
parlare bene figoni ingegneri economisti
è stato interessante ecco questo pure mi
ha fatto molto crescere è la sfida a cui
ho risposto anche la matematica
sicuramente e secondo me si può credere
a questo fare networking perché ancora
adesso per quanto i sistemi sociali oi
sistemi andiamo ad analizzare sono
estremamente complessi secondo me vale
ancora quello che diceva 500 anni fa
galilei e che ancora anche questi
sistemi così complessi quindi nel grande
libro della natura è scritto comunque in
un linguaggio che è la matematica grazie
[Applauso]